I'm sorry everyone I uh wouldn't stop hiccuping before stream I wouldn't stop
hiccuping before stream and then I drank a lot of water I wouldn't stop
hiccuping and then I stopped hiccuping and then my tummy started to hurt really
badly. But hello everyone. Serenity raided me I missed it I'm sorry. Serenity
still here thank you for the raid and welcome everyone to the stream welcome
Senpai. Today we are playing a game called Deathmark. I won't lie to you I've
played a bit of this game before but then I put it on a very long hiatus and
totally forgot about everything that happened to it and I did this twice
already. So if I feel like I'm starting to remember some stuff that's why and I'm
on a completely new account. Let's go! I mean hold on. Let's go!
Hey want to hit up the karaoke place? The new love and hero song is out.
I'm not feeling it. I'm not feeling up to it today. This story creeped me out
earlier. Do you want to hear it? Oh chair. You remember Miss Yamaguchi? She wears
those big glasses. I heard she's gone missing. What? No one knows where she is?
Nope she just disappeared. Just up and poofed from the library. Okay new voice
time. One of the student librarians said she was researching something there but
then she vanished. But she's super diligent right? One of the students thought
it was weird that she'd up and leave like that. So he checked in on her. But when he
did, the only thing left was her arm. Had her really weird scar on it. So it was
definitely her arm. A scar? Yeah. It looked like a dog bite. He showed it to me
once. Had no idea where it came from. Burial? There was a scar like that on
Miki's leg too. Huh? Miki? Wait that's the girl who went missing. Yeah. It's crazy. Maybe
that rumor's true. The one about the cursed scar. Cut it out. You're scaring me. I forgot
which Valley Girl was who now. Sorry. I hear snatches of an idiotic ghost stories. They're
speaking seriously. It's obvious that they don't believe a word. They're only
killing time. Rumors are the best way to do that. The sun's about to set. It's gotten
later than I planned. I shouldn't have stuck around to hear that story. I better hurry.
Bye tonight else. Thunder rumbles in the distance. A huge mansion is in front of me. Strange.
I'm sure I was just. My vision blurs. My ears are buzzing. My head's swimming. It's
almost like I'm drunk. What time is it? A glass at my wrist, but my watch is gone. I
put it in my coat pocket. And all I find is a business card. In elegant printed letters
is a name. Saya Kujo, spirit healer. On the back is a photo of the mansion. I guess this
must be Kujo Mansion then? Kujo Mansion, Saya Kujo. Those names sound familiar somehow.
One way to find out, taking a deep breath, I reach out to knock. I stop when I see something
on my wrist. It's a strange scar. Wonder that. I could just be imagining this, but feel an
icy chill when I look at it. My fur, my fists pounds on the door, no reply. A light appears
in the second floor window. It's probably too far from the door for them to hear me
knocking. Don't they have doorbells in this day and age? I grafts the door knob and find
it unlocked. No point in staying outside. I'll just go in. I'll apologize to the owner
later. Inside is shrouded in darkness. A small beam of light from the window is the
only way I can see anything in here. It's dead silent except for the constant ticking
of a clock's second hand. I must be in the entrance hall. The atrium extends to the second
floor. Anyone home? There's no reply to my shout. Maybe they've soundproofed this place
so they can't hear me downstairs. I guess I need to go upstairs then. A staircase is
just visible up ahead. I walk towards it, cutting across the hall. With what light? My ears catch a
strange noise. I turn to look where it's coming from. Someone's there. I fell up by the dark.
I think they're staring at me. What should we do? Ten pie! I'm gonna approach them. What do you
guys want to do? I'm gonna approach them. Gulping. I hesitantly make my way over.
Trepidation slowing my steps. Ooh! Trepidation! That's a good idea. Word of the day everyone!
Trepidation! It's a young girl. She doesn't move an inch as I approach. Girl, you just had
your eyes open. I know you did. At least it seems that way to me. Doesn't look like she's even
breathing. They're corpse? Great, I creep myself out. I start to sweat. What should I do?
Sampai! I'm gonna do the bad touch. The shaky hand, I slowly reach out and touch your skin.
I'm not sure what I expected, but it feels unnatural somehow. It's stiff and cold.
I press down on her arm and she makes the strange sound I heard earlier. Ah, now it makes sense.
She's a doll. A doll's joint creak when they move. That's what made the noise. Not a relief if disappointing.
I carefully begin climbing the stairs, making sure not to trip.
As I reach the landing, the sharp sound of a bell breaks the silence. It seems to be coming from above me.
Looking up, I can spy the outline of a cloth. I bet that's what's making the sound.
Should we approach it? Approach it or wait? What do you think, Sampai?
It's a group activity. Wait, wait, wait, okay.
Okay, let's see.
I saw wait first, so we're gonna do wait.
I pause and wait for the clamor to end.
It doesn't seem to be stopping. Maybe it's broken. Okay, I guess we don't wait then.
Should we approach it then?
Approach it menacingly.
Oh, the noise guides me over.
It's an antique grandfather clock. The noise is definitely coming from here.
I reach toward the glass to check inside.
All of a sudden, it stops chiming.
Silence descends, broken only by ticking.
I guess it's fixed now, but that timing was a little too spot on. Was it really a coincidence?
All these strange occurrences make me uneasy, but I continue on to the room with the light.
Stopping in front of the door, I knock.
But again, there's no reply.
I try again several times, even calling out, but there's still no answer. I push on the door.
It's dark inside. What's that on the ground?
Strange, I definitely saw lights on in here when I was outside.
Wafting through the room is an odd smell.
It's sugary, like ripe fruit. The whole room is permeated with it.
Some kind of aromatherapy, maybe? And a particularly pleasant smell, though.
The aroma draws me further into the room.
And the floor under my feet feels off. It's wet.
It dawns on me that I'm smelling something else mixed with the sweet smell.
Chat sometimes blocks the dialogue window. Can you adjust the game screen?
Okie dokie.
It doesn't look that great, but is this okay, Senpai?
Good.
Well, you didn't want to just hear the sound of my voice. You needed your subtitles so that you can go along with me.
We need to practice reading for your USL classes, of course. Okie dokie.
But, like, oh yeah, I clicked off the screen. I know this scent. This metallic tang.
Lightning flashes, then catch a glimpse of something.
The startling grotesque object stretches out across the floor beneath my feet.
Something strange is there.
What should we do? Stare at it?
Should we stare at it? We're gonna stare.
Alright. So bizarre that I can't stop staring.
Blooming flowers are everywhere.
They're bursting out of the woman's stomach. A blood-soaked body overwhelmed with them.
I really hate the look of Lotus Pods. I absolutely hate the look of him.
I wrench my gaze away, horrified. But the hellish image is burned into my mind. I can feel my entire body shaking.
Bio-Rises. I'm gonna throw up. Haha, what's new?
In the next instant, the lights are on.
Wait, that's not all. The body is gone, leaving only a stain.
This doesn't make sense. Bad dream, at least. I'd really, had really much preferred if it was
the faint smell that remains in the blood-stained crush my any hope I had of it.
I beat a retreat from the room in an effort to escape this whole bizarre situation.
When I stumble back into the hall, the lights are on in here as well.
I decide to have another look around. While the furnishing in here are old enough to be antiques,
I match this old-fashioned mansion.
A large doll sits on a couch. This must be the figure I saw in the dark.
One would easily mistake this for a human if they couldn't see the ball joints.
Probably belongs to the owner of the mansion.
But what do I do now?
Contact the police?
Their stomach was full of flour, sir, and the corpse stopped and vanished like fog.
Like anyone would believe that.
Welcome. Welcome to Kujo Mansion.
The doll moved and spoke.
A different kind of shutter runs through me, and the one I found, the corpse.
Up until this point, I was nothing more than an observer to all these freaky events.
I could distance myself from it, but now a doll is talking to me.
Have I startled you?
If so, I sincerely apologize.
My master ordered me to behave like a normal doll until told otherwise.
The words are elegant and refined, but her face never moves an inch.
She may look human, but she clearly isn't.
She slowly folds her hands together, though she can move too.
I'm sorry for not introducing myself.
I'm called Mary.
You have likely seen a number of oddities here already.
I see my master, Zaya Kujo, was unable to escape from the mark then.
Zaya Kujo, does she mean that corpse?
But wait, what about this mark?
What about this bell to mark?
Lady Zaya was searching for a way to escape the mark.
Were you not also called here by her because of the mark on your arm?
She must be talking about this weird scar.
Did Zaya Kujo invite me to this mansion?
When I try to remember, my head hurts.
I have something to tell you in place of my light master,
but I would like to ask one thing first.
Do you know your own name?
Well, that was a much simpler question than I had been expecting.
It's...
I break out into a sweat.
My throat is drying up.
Why?
Why can't I answer?
I'm shocked to find I'm coming up blank.
I see.
Then it is as I thought.
Somehow, Mary knows what's going on with me.
Before I offer an explanation, please decide on a temporary name.
Things will go much easier if I have a name I wish to call you.
It is also likely you will find it hard to remain calm if you are nameless.
She's probably right.
Better to have some placeholder name than continue life as a hollow nameless being.
Enter the protagonist's last name, up to 10 letters.
Okay, delete.
No, no, no, no, no.
Last name.
First name.
Oops.
We have to deduce formalities, of course.
He's literally you, for real, for real.
Senpai, Senpai.
Can't it be Senpai Modest?
No, I have to take your last name, Senpai.
So it's Senpai Senpai.
Yes.
It's Senpai Senpai, okay.
It cannot be changed.
Yeah.
Not Darling Senpai?
Well, then it would say Darling.
Depending on the person, they'll say Darling-san, Senpai-san.
I want to Senpai-san, Senpai-san.
Okay.
You okay with others calling you Senpai?
Of course.
Now, if they have a crush on you, on the other hand, that's different.
After all, Senpai must be Senpai in every situation.
Besides, if you die, that's just in character, isn't it?
She berayed.
Excuse me, I got to adjust myself.
Okay.
Welcome, Raiders.
Welcome.
Welcome my baby girl.
She be cotton bomb.
Welcome to the stream.
Welcome, welcome.
We are naming the protagonist right now.
How was your stream?
I totally forgot what you were playing because I was out all day.
Gosh, I love my gen mate so much.
But I can go back and be like, hold on.
Fine, fine.
You guys, you have variety now.
Fine.
I'll give you variety, Senpai.
I went Dar-villor.
V-Darling.
Wow, that's going to be...
When is someone going to start that up, huh?
Chibis was fighting tamper vampires, now fighting Fa.
Like the food, right?
Oh, I spelled Senpai wrong.
Do I even love Senpai if I spell Senpai's name wrong?
Oh, fuck it.
There we go.
Senpai, darling.
Okay?
The dyslexia hitting.
Oh, oh, we get to choose our luck.
Senpai, you get to choose the luck.
Look, do you want glasses and beard?
Beard?
Just glasses?
Nothing?
You want to wear glasses?
You want to just have a beard?
Just glasses?
I just see glasses.
Okay, glasses it is.
It's this okay?
Yeah, let's fucking go.
I'm...
Excuse me.
I'm Senpai, darling.
Understood, Lord Darling.
Now, I shall explain to you about the mark.
It is the Seal of Death.
Those who have it will soon die.
You do not believe me?
I'm certain this sounds absurd to want to know.
I'm sure it's the seal of death.
I'm certain this sounds absurd to want you as loved at an eventful life.
However, my master's death proves it to be irrefutably true.
The Carps?
The Carp's sweet stench comes back to me.
It didn't seem like the work of humans.
I'm afraid that the horror of the mark does not stop there.
Victims slowly lose their memories until the day they die.
They face death all the while suffering from the terror of losing oneself.
Memory loss?
I can't be that.
That would mean that I'm...
Yes.
The fact that you have forgotten your name proves that death is coming.
Lord Darling, you...
...will die this very dawn.
Death mark.
Yes, I think I named the protagonist aptly.
Remember, senpai, your mortality is always finite.
My memories skip forward a bit after that.
I just remember being completely stunned at what Mary revealed to me.
I can probably attribute it to memory loss caused by the mark.
The next thing I know...
...I'm lying in a guest room in the mansion.
I vaguely recall dragging myself up the stairs and coming here.
I must have fallen asleep at some point, and thanks to that I feel a lot better.
I'll die at dawn, huh?
I try saying it out loud.
It's definitely shocking, but I can't say it feels real yet.
It doesn't make sense, way out of the blue.
But if it's true, is waiting for my untimely death the only thing I can do?
It might be a good idea to ask Mary more about it.
I find Mary sitting in the exact same spot as before.
She hasn't moved an inch.
I doubt a doll gets bored waiting like humans do.
Good morning.
Good morning, Lord, darling.
Maybe we should save before I do something crazy?
Is there a save option?
Are you... are you feeling better now?
Well, how do you feel, Senpai?
Yeah, you're fine.
Fine, Senpai, you're all fine.
Sort of?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, okay, I see more yeses.
That's good to hear.
Yeah, I'm gonna adjust my voice for her, give me a second.
Since it appears that you have calmed down, I would like to ask you a question.
Okay, yeah, I think this is better.
What do you guys think?
What does Senpai think?
Yeah, I'm gonna go up here.
What will you do now?
I can guide you down only two paths.
The first is to wait for death.
The second is to fight the mark.
Can... can you help me?
If that is what you wish, yes.
My master was researching the mark.
A few days prior to her death, he found a way to escape it.
Regretfully, she passed away before she was able to inform me.
So she doesn't know anything after all.
There is some time yet before dawn.
You have a slim chance.
Salvation is a thin thread dangling from heaven.
Would you put that you would grab hold of?
And I shall do my utmost to help.
What will you do?
I guess this boils down to whether I trust her.
If she's right about all this, my time on earth is up at dawn.
If I don't want to die, then there's no other choice but to resist the mark until then.
If she's lying, I'll be fine when the morning comes.
And am I really alright with that?
Aw, I got blinded.
People are being killed in nonsensical, grotesque ways.
Am I going to turn a blind eye to it?
This is a life or death decision.
I need to think about it carefully.
Live or die.
Deadly choice.
You will be faced with choices that can result in death.
It is limited time and your soul power will continue to drain.
Time's up or wrong answers will result in a game over.
So be quick, but also careful in finding the right answers.
Restoring soul power.
Completing a deadly choice will restore some soul power.
Accelerated dialogue.
Dialogue will be sped up while pressing the left button.
But certain dialogue cannot be sped up.
Backlog.
Start with display previous dialogue.
Auto mode.
The right button will activate auto mode.
Hiding the dialogue window.
You can hide the dialogue window by pressing Y.
Then I shall ask you, will you quietly wait for death or struggle against the mark?
We're going to fight the mark, obviously.
Safe.
Survived.
I've decided to trust you.
As you say, Lord Diving.
Then I shall carry out the dying wish of my master and aid you.
I cannot do much, but feel free to request anything you wish of me.
I made up my mind, but that doesn't mean I know what I should do.
And I'll squat about the supernatural and losing my memory makes research impossible.
I don't have a moment to lose.
A knock comes from the front door.
It would come here this late at night.
Oh my, what a sign of fate.
It seems the other markbearers have arrived.
Is it instinct that she knows these things?
Maybe she has some kind of mysterious power being a talking doll and all.
I beg your pardon, Lord Diving.
I do apologize.
But could you go greet our guests in my stead?
They may experience a shock of a doll such as myself welcomes them.
Moreover, while I'm able to move my arms, I am unable to walk.
I move to the front door to greet our guests.
People fated to die like me.
I wonder what they're like.
Who I find at the door are not who I expect to see this late at night.
A high schooler and a small boy.
These kids have the mark?
No way.
Um, we came to see Professor Kujo.
Who are you?
I can't say I'm a total stranger since I'm here at the mansion.
I'm...
So...
What do you want?
Sampai?
Do you want to be...
her relative?
Her disciple?
Her relative or disciple?
No!
Boyfriend is not an option!
No option!
You're mine!
Mine!
Sampai's cheating on me.
You're not going to make me cry, right?
Okay, let's go with relative.
Oh.
So, you're her older brother.
Your eyes do kind...
Do look kind similar.
Sorry, I've decided to go on with a different voice for her already.
She seems to know Saiyaku-jou.
I think about it, that business card did say Spirit Healer.
Going off this girl's acceptance.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Going off this girl's accessories, I get the feeling she's a huge occult fan.
I'm Moe Watanabe.
I'm here to talk to her about this article she wrote in no...
Oop! Oop! Arts!
Monthly!
She pulls out an occult magazine out of her bag.
Inside is a picture of the mark.
Accompanying articles as the scar is.
A soul-inhibiting disease that erases memories inquire at Kujo Mansion.
Um, this is the same scar, right?
Moe ellipses her skirt up a bit to show me her leg.
Don't look, Senpai!
Right there on her right thigh is the mark.
I think I know what the article means by erasing memories.
I've been super forgetful lately.
I'm even blanking on my friend's names.
That's never happened to me before.
Do you think the scar is doing it?
This article is obviously bogus.
The young boy scoffs.
Even kids know better than to believe in ghosts or curses these days.
And a high schooler fell for it.
You must be embarrassed about this.
But Tsukasa, where did you hang around in the front of the Williams Mansion's key?
Biss up, your scar scares you.
Tsukasa seems to have no retort for that.
He silently soaks.
Looks like a bullseye.
It's clear they're both mark-bearers.
Better bring them over to meet Mary.
Moe shrieks excitingly as she gets close.
Oh my god, it's so cute!
It's a doll, yeah?
I've never seen one this big before.
The craftsmanship is so detailed.
It's almost like it's alive.
They're both admiring her one.
Welcome to Kujo Mansion.
What?
It's Spock.
With that, the two new visitors join our numbers.
They enter this monstrous world.
That hover on the precipice of death.
Mary tells Moe and Tsukasa about the mark once they regain their composure.
All about the steady memory loss and their imminent death.
It sounds like a ridiculous story, but it gains validity coming from someone like her.
Both of their faces pale.
Now, if you came specifically here because you believe that Lady Sia's article.
You must have already experienced the pain of losing your memories.
Moe admitted as much earlier, but I can see Tsukasa's face darken.
So it must be happening to him too.
Oh, what kind of tea today?
I for gore, give me a second as I regain my memory.
I for gore, maybe I have a death mark too.
The funny thing is that I specifically picked out this tea
because I knew Senpai's would ask, but then I forgot.
Give me a second.
Ah, okay.
I remember.
I remember now.
It's Tulsi.
Tulsi Ginger.
Tulsi.
I was just about to google the tea brand and be like,
maybe if I look at the labels, I would remember.
Is it any good?
And yeah, I think so.
It's got kind of like a mellow or earthy taste.
Tulsi.
T-U-L-S-I.
Like, there's a VTuber with that name.
There's a VTuber with that name.
I think she's with Sony.
I would repeat a meme that went around.
About her.
Or a viral tweet that went around about her.
But that might not be safe for YouTube.
She's on the JP side.
I know, I know, I know.
I know Senpai.
I will give you a hint.
I'll give you a hint.
Someone mistook
15, 15, 15 men, meaning years, and translated to 15,
about 15,000.
I think 15,000 men, so men being year, to 15,000 men.
So I'll let your imagination go wild with that.
I actually watched her debut and everyone was trolling her.
Of course, Sony did a cease and desist on that.
So you'll have to just do, well, what did they, what do you guys say?
Do your reps?
Yeah, you have to do your reps.
Also, yeah, this week's homework.
It's hard to catch up with the lingo that lots of people use.
I'm getting, I'm getting, I'm getting a like crash course on like what, what some things mean.
So yeah,
that was, that was really fun.
Actually, I hear she's a very nice person.
So yeah, I really do like her design though.
If you're, if you're a fan of,
um, canoes, canoes, like, like, uh, I see, or Emmy, you might like her design.
It must be happening to him too.
I'm going to scoot in closer.
I was totally the wrong voice.
Okay, okay.
The peachy kind of light color.
Why do I call them canoes?
Canoe.
I'm making things up.
But I'm talking about, you know, the little, little canoes.
You know, the boat, you paddle.
Hey, Moe, I'd like to confirm something.
Where were you when you got the mark?
Amnesia seems to be worse than theirs.
They might remember.
The canoes need correction, right?
Yeah, they need to be corrected
so that they can, you know, float correctly.
They might, so they might remember.
I'm not positive, but
I think my mark might have been a curse from Hana Hiko.
Hana Hiko.
Thank you, Senpai.
Beto the snippet.
Mercy is the only person who is entirely charm points
and we're all lucky to be her Senpai.
Oh, thank you.
You are all lucky.
But thank you, Senpai, for the 420.
This name is familiar to me.
He's the ghost of the resident children of this town whisper about, right?
Oh, sorry, it's correct.
My master was interested in him.
So Sayakujo was interested, was curious too, could be connected to the mark some day.
I'd like to hear more about this ghost.
As you wish, Lord Darling.
And I shall tell you the rumors of Hana Hiko.
Chapter one.
Hana Hiko.
Sorry, I need to do a cuter laugh, right?
Oh, did you hear?
Oops, that was my controller.
About the ghost boy, all the schools in H City are talking about.
Sounds like Hana Hiko is back.
I heard he can appear if you peek in the school mirror at night or ask you something.
Am I pretty?
If you tell him no, you'll be fine, but you say yes.
I need that red stuff, then.
It just disappears.
But that's not all.
Hana Hiko hates adults, you know.
I heard that if the person he asks is an adult, they'll die.
They'll not just drop dead.
Blood is drained from them.
And next to the carts is a single rose.
Arrows dripping with blood.
Remakes can be easily manipulated, passing from one person to another.
Assumptions and errors mix in, but they also hold a hint of truth.
Miss Moe, do you know anything else?
I probably cut my mark when I was investigating Hana Hiko at each elementary school.
That's got to be some sort of clue.
I should ask her more about it.
Why were you at H Elementary?
My big dream is to write about the cult.
I'd love to see a ghost.
I found this article in a magazine mentioning Hana Hiko was seen there.
I figured that place would be easier to sneak in than a regular school,
since it's been closed down.
What should I ask next?
Was Hana Hiko there?
I don't think so, but I can't really say for sure.
I went to the mirror, but a shipper suddenly ran down my spine and I got spooked and left.
What should I ask next?
When did you notice the mark?
I noticed it later in the bath.
A strange scar was suddenly on my thigh.
It really surprised me.
I realized immediately it had to be what Professor Kujo wrote about.
Fellow high-patch haver, I have an iPad in real life.
Twinsies!
You know, when I think, I think I recall.
Is this a spoiler?
But I did guess this before I played the game.
Well, no, when I first played the game, I think I guessed that the red stuff is like lipstick or something.
Rouge, perhaps?
Perhaps Rouge?
I don't know what kind of makeup.
They had in Japan, really.
I think I have a handle on what happened.
No way to know for sure about the ghost, but if there's no denying,
she had the mark after returning home from age elementary.
And then, maybe, Tsukasa glanced down at his left hand.
The line might be from behind a Hiko tooth.
I noticed it after I got home from tea elementary.
That ghost was seen a lot in schools in each city, right?
Maybe he remembered something, but I asked him some questions too.
Tea elementary?
Got a school there.
You've probably heard of it since it's a top ranked elementary in each city.
What should I ask next?
When was that?
A year-round sunset?
I was heading home until I realized I forgot something and turned back.
Should I ask Mips and just see Hena Hiko?
No, and I didn't get chills or anything either.
Oh, but I think I passed a mirror.
I went to the bathroom before going home.
I don't think he knows anymore.
Stories are pretty similar to the Hena Hiko rooms.
They can't just be coins in this.
You must invest to eat the places for Hena Hiko up here.
For their sake, as well as yours.
Ah, well, that sounds all well and good, but...
What exactly am I investigating?
Death and life coexistence.
The mark originated there, and a way to erase it will also be there.
Did I get breathier for her voice?
Oh my goodness, I can't keep track of the voices I'm making for each character.
I must be so tired some pie.
I must be so tired.
No, that was totally not the voice I did.
I did like a really creepy voice, huh?
My bad.
You must find it.
Break the key.
You need to break the mark's curse.
Wait, find the key, and then I'll make the...
Oh my gosh, oh.
Maybe doing a visual novel for my last day of my debut week was definitely...
It was definitely a little bit short-sighted on my side.
That is the only way to escape.
And all of a sudden, a huge burden was dropped on my shoulders.
We can go back to Harvester?
No, no, no.
If I pick something, we're playing that today unless it's like completely terrible.
But I will add Harvester back onto the schedule.
Probably the week after.
It seems...
It seems that Hanahiko appeared at two schools.
Where will you investigate?
Okay, okay.
Logic time.
Logic time, Senpai.
We're probably going to go to H Elementary instead of T Elementary,
because T Elementary is most likely severely guarded since it's a prestigious school,
and H Elementary might not be as guarded.
Are we still doing Markiller 7 as well?
Of course.
Yeah, that's probably wise.
I'd arrest you on the spot if you tried to sneak into a regular school.
I told you!
H Elementary might be a-ha-h-ha-aunted.
Scared of a little security?
Yeah, just a little bit.
A middle-aged man who can't recall his name,
let alone his address or job title.
Would have no excuse if I got caught.
Wanna get going then?
Let's do this!
Wait, you're coming too?
Of course!
I haven't given up on seeing Hanahiko yet.
She grins at me.
Is she really strong, or is this blind optimism?
I'm going too.
Hey, not you two, seriously.
My life's on the line here.
I don't want the reason I die to be,
because you messed up something.
You messed something up.
Oh, dang!
This kid has no just on me and me, and they'll be right!
That's pretty bold.
Good thing you're cute.
But to bring kids along with me is...
I understand your hesitation,
but the mark does not discriminate,
stealing lives of children and adults.
They wish to fight their fate.
We should honor that.
I suppose human logic doesn't fly
when dealing with the supernatural.
We'll need to prepare ourselves
for the worst if we're gonna survive.
Please take only one mark bearer with you, however.
A large group will increase the odds
of you being detected by spirits.
I also ask that you not waste time
dwindling with others on the way.
It is possible.
Unnecessary contact may hasten the effect of the mark.
Only engage when absolutely necessary.
Keep contact with others to a minimum.
Yeah, that's what I'm gonna say.
Have a safe trip.
Okay, we are not bringing the tiny child.
Selecting a partner.
First, select a mark bearer.
Do this in partner menu.
Oh, yeah!
Hey, mister!
How do you think it'll be a good idea
to take notes on what Mary's told us?
Your memory's getting worse all the time.
We don't want to forget anything.
I don't know when I'll lose my memory again.
All right, down all the information I get
and keep it in my file.
Something in it might just save our lives at some point.
New info was added to the spirit file
rumor of Hanna Hiko other.
Spirit file.
Important info on spirits will be added
to the spirit file.
Check it from your bag.
Consult it if you need help.
Saving and loading.
Save at the mansion or hunts.
Return to the title screen from the bag
to live for your luck to load.
Then choose continue.
Wait, X to save.
Ho, ho, ho!
Look, we finally got the save.
Partner.
We are not taking the smart one.
The smart mouth and child.
I would want to leave this kid behind.
We'll take, we'll take.
I knew it!
I knew her voice was ganky.
Did you hear that?
She's super ganky.
Big.
Okay, Hanna Hiko.
Okay, that's not all.
Kujo mansion.
Yes, adults.
It hates adults.
Okay, the red stuff.
Okay, and.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Not that.
Exit.
First, first we have to get to H elementary.
Am I pretty ganky?
Ganky Senpai.
I feel like I'm pretty ganky, but.
But I, I also maybe not.
I'm maybe not the most gankiest.
Super ganky.
Mary says we're free to use the car in the garage.
The garage is attached from the mansion.
The vintage model van in bicycles only sent the elegant interior.
Thank God for careless people.
The car key was left in the table.
Time to go.
Uh, hey.
According to Mary, you lost a bunch of your memories, right?
Is it okay for you to drive?
She looks at me suspiciously.
Don't worry, it'll be fine, I think.
I'll come back when I take the wheel.
Part of that is to convince myself.
Well, aren't you missing your license?
If a cop finds us, we'll have more to worry about than Hanahiko.
She's right about that.
But I have a license.
But this is not me, this is Senpai.
Senpai, do you have a license?
But our lives are on the line, so we don't have much of a choice.
Okay, okay, okay.
Then we're safe if, if more than, if a good, if a handful of Senpais can drive, will survive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Once the mark's gone, I'll remember.
I'm surprised that a lot of you don't have a driver's license, actually.
Then I'll probably just have them reissue it, assuming I ever got one.
Oh, now I'm even more worried.
Just drive safe, okay?
Let's head to H. elementary.
Hoteru.
Human bodies are remarkable.
Back in the garage, I wasn't sure if I'd be able to drive or not.
But the second my hand touched the wheel, I wasn't worried anymore.
I must have reacted quicker than I expected.
And now, it's now easy to guide this monster down the road.
Now, thoughts of what I can no longer do start to filter in my head.
Hey, mister.
Moe pipes up hesitantly.
I should have put more.
I put too much ganky in that.
I'd probably let the silence go on too long.
It doesn't seem as cheerful as she was a little while ago.
What's it like to lose your memories?
That's a hard question to answer.
What do you mean?
Like, do they all go at once?
Or a few pieces at a time?
I can't believe I'm just like, just like, hey, mister.
She said, hesitantly, hey, mister.
Tea.
What if you're only left with sad memories?
I'd hate that.
I don't think it works like that, but I have no idea if it's getting worse or better.
I don't know what I was like to begin with, so there's nothing to compare to.
In that sense, rather than the memories vanishing,
like everything's been painted white, but it feels like.
Oh, you sure I'm mature, mister?
Take everything so calmly.
No, no, no, no, no, no, senpais do not paint it white.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We are facing.
We are facing some ghosts right now.
The conversation dwindles, leaving only the sound of the tires on the road.
Then thoughts start popping into my head again, one after another.
I know we have to check out that mirror.
What else should we investigate?
What do you think?
The white glance is over it.
No idea.
I can't even remember my own name.
How the hell am I supposed to know what we're doing?
Oh, please.
I'm really counting on you.
Think about everything.
I'm talking to a child.
I need to show restraint and be a good example.
But that's definitely how I really feel.
Mercy, this girl is kind of clingy.
She's just a kid.
I'm pretty clingy.
Do you have problems with that, senpai?
I stare down the steering wheel.
Ah, flashbang.
No, no problem.
Not only Mercy, it's okay.
Also, your coral if it's a kid, gotcha.
What are you implying, senpai?
I'm saying that you would not have any interest in kids, right?
Senpai?
Amy and Icy don't count.
They don't count.
No, they don't count.
Amy is immortal, and I don't know how old Icy is in bear,
but bear, but old enough in human years.
Okay.
You're not interested in high schoolers, right, senpai?
Except for me, right?
An adult who's sort of role-playing a high schooler.
I know I'm a college.
I'm college.
Wait, I'm college.
I made a mistake.
I just like high school uniforms.
Listen, they don't wear sayfuku in university.
This is just aesthetics.
Shut the fuck up.
Memory loss beam.
You will forget that I made a fucking lucky boo.
Let's continue the game.
Yeah.
Who's that doll here?
Oh, yeah, let's do the game.
A doll in the mansion.
Markbearers.
Yo, senpai, you forgot.
You dozed off a little.
We're playing death mark, remember?
The mark spirits.
And the mysterious deaths.
Can't remember, must be the mark.
Oh, no, we should go exercise these spirits.
Yeah, it's okay.
It's okay if senpai is passed out.
I'm always taking care of senpai.
Also, yeah, senpai has been in a loving relationship with me for a long time,
and we're going to have three kids, okay?
Feel like I'm going to be buried
under all the crushing thoughts that keep popping into my mind.
I think three is a good number.
I think three per senpai is a good number.
What awaits me down the dark road?
I actually, to be honest, I don't know.
What I'm saying?
I think actually three kids in total is fine.
Okay, yeah, it's been a long week.
I've been, I've been just saying shit.
I feel a flutter, flutter, flutter, and mark on my wrist like it's trying to warn me.
My brain might not be able to understand, but my body can sense it.
That death is closing in.
You want daughters or son more?
Um, I don't know.
I feel like daughters are cuter,
but like, I wouldn't mind a son either.
Anyways, it doesn't matter.
I'll love them no matter what.
If that's happening, isn't the problem.
It's more how long do I have left?
How much, how much longer is it?
I almost yell, but I managed to swallow it down with effort.
I think we're almost there.
Even if our kids are worms, even if you are a worm, Senpai, I would still love you.
Really?
It's closer than I thought.
Yeah, yeah, exactly right.
Or at any time it could
It's a lot closer than you think.
Looming ominously in the moonlight, the school definitely looks abandoned.
For quite a number of years, in fact, these walls are starting to crack.
All the windows are broken as well.
A thick chain is in front of the main gate to keep people from going in.
Hey, you there, not another step.
An enthusiastic voice comes from a man in a guard uniform.
You must be patrolling the area like we got caught.
This property belongs to the city.
No one's allowed in, didn't you know?
Or are you up to something?
A bunch of people have been coming here on dares since it's haunted.
You aren't one of them, are you?
It's haunted?
Oh, give me a second.
Um, it's haunted?
Oh, I didn't know that.
Damn, is it haunted?
Oh, that's what the rumors are saying anyway.
It's just a great pain.
Oh, he nods in agreement.
It is pretty famous after all.
The guard sighs.
Anyway, the school is off limits, so you can't go inside.
I don't want any trouble on my first shift here.
Please leave.
You know.
Okay.
I'm muttering to himself.
The guard makes his way into the school.
As we watch him leave, Moe leans over and whispers.
Damn, it wasn't a guard when I stuck in here before.
I did not get caught.
Moving around a haunt.
Use the...
Lease keys to move.
The map shows which way you're facing and where you can go.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh.
Pushing open the doors I head inside.
Oh, it's so dark.
I can't see anything like this.
The moonlight doesn't reach inside.
We'll have to use the flashlight.
But if we use the flashlight, that guard will find us.
And do anything about it, I guess.
Anyway, that mirror is...
I'm pretty sure it's on the right.
To the right on the staircase.
Okay.
Instagating a haunt.
Move the L to search the current area.
Shine the flashlight in areas of interest and press A.
Pressing B ends the search.
Using the pad.
The search and move.
Um, look.
Do not leave hand prints in the mirror in the eastern staircase.
Thank you.
Independent research presentation.
First floor.
Multi-purpose classroom.
Come check it out.
Wow, that presentation takes me back.
Anyway, the mirror is on the eastern staircase.
It's the one I saw.
Guess we'll go there first.
Yeah, it's to the right.
Let me investigate, bish.
Yo, I turn over the torn flyer.
And I don't find anything in particular.
Nothing's there, huh?
Looks like it.
Cool.
Um, and...
Anything else?
Ooh!
There are platforms of broken wooden slats in front of this true rock.
They creak when we step on them.
Record?
Uh...
Oh, that's one.
Half torn poster.
Says lost and found in large letters at the top.
Look, lost items are kept in the storage in the staff room.
Please check if you're missing something.
Deal.
Touch the paper.
It disintegrates.
Second, my fingers reach it and scatters through the air.
Nothing else looks interesting.
Okay, anything else we can look at?
The ceiling is filthy and the fluorescent lights are broken.
All right, I think that's it.
Went to the right.
Huh?
As we enter the hallway, a small shadow flits across our feet.
Turn the flashlight and find.
Huh? A bunny!
It's so cute!
Huh.
A bunny!
What's... is it the school pet?
Uh, how long has the school been closed for?
I don't think so.
I don't think the banyoumi's there.
Chibi's more of a blonde bunny.
Is the bunny from Ghost Stories?
Touch me.
Touch me harder.
The black rabbit squeaks and runs away.
It rushes towards the eastern end of the school.
Ah, I ran away.
Is it telling us to follow?
Haha, you're right.
New info was added to the spirit file.
Black rabbit.
Uh, spooky.
It looks like something smashed the fluorescent lights.
Their shadowed beyond repair.
Should we go into the classroom?
I'm gonna do it.
Maybe we can find something cool.
It's abandoned desk.
On desk is slightly rusty.
Turn the desk around and stick my hand inside.
Got a holy, holy hard hat.
I doubt that's very useful.
You never know.
The dust is thick on the ceiling.
That just walking around causes a shower of particles.
I think that's it in this room.
I can't.
Moved forward.
Down here.
Seems to be locked.
Broken window is letting in a piercingly cold wind.
The door is locked.
Locked door.
I wonder if we could wrench it open by sticking the letter opening into the hole.
Give it a try, but it won't even fit inside.
Wow, so uncool.
Put the fuck up!
The floor tile is upheeled off, leaving bare concrete.
I wonder if I can just peel around.
Keyhole isn't rusted over.
If I had a key, I could open it.
Okay.
What platform did you first play this on, Mercy?
Um...
PS4.
I think.
The fire door is rusted shut and won't move.
Hi.
Shut the fuck up!
That's my job!
Climb the stairs.
Don't copy me stinking.
Stinking ghost.
This is it.
The mirror I saw last time, I'm sure of it.
Huh?
Just then a dull pain runs through my wrists.
Like something is biting into my skin.
To distract myself from the pain.
I keep talking with Moe.
Certainly looks normal.
Yeah, what should we do?
I feel like I should save.
I suddenly face the mirror, bringing my face up to it.
Into its cloudy surface.
As expected, I can't make anything else.
I see my own shadow reflected as a vague shadowy lump.
Shadow sways in the mirror.
At least that's what I thought at first.
I figured the shadow moved because I had.
The next time the shadow moves, a cold shiver runs down my spine.
That's not my shadow.
Okay, okay, you remember the story of Hanahiko, right?
We say no, you're not pretty, and we are not an adult.
Some things in the mirror.
Sorry, I'm going to try to do a Moe.
Moe yelps and steps back.
That confirms I'm not hallucinating.
There really is something in there.
Every muscle in my body locks.
Try to look away, but I can't even close my eyes.
Figure's mouth twists.
I don't know look, but I can't even close my eyes.
It opens his mouth.
An unvoiced pierces my ears.
Live or die.
Hey, am I pretty?
No, no, right?
Yes, safe!
Only I had that red stuff.
Can't see well.
You a grown-up?
No, no, I'm not a grown-up.
Uh-uh.
I'm the tallest in my class.
Big people aren't allowed in school.
Suddenly the mirror cracks.
I'm just, I was just pretty tall.
Actually, oh no, no, no, I'm not going to tell the story.
I'm not going to tell the story because my senpais will make fun of me.
Suddenly the mirror cracks.
Big crack now.
I can't see no more big people here.
We would never.
Okay, so you know how I'm five, five, three in freedom units, right?
Okay, fine.
I'll tell the story.
So I stopped growing around fifth grade.
And I was the tallest in my class.
And I was so happy.
And then the following year, everyone shot way past me.
And I was like, oh, okay.
A brief fleeting moment of glory.
I was, I was the tallest.
And then I was not immediately after.
All right, the figure disappears.
Survived.
Whew.
The scream echoes from the other side of the school.
Moe sinks to the floor.
The gasping panic disbelief for a while.
I feel much the same.
What was that?
Probably an ahiqo.
I couldn't say it.
The words stuck in my throat.
My mouth is completely dry.
I can't believe this.
I, I thought I wanted to see a ghost.
But just see one that clearly.
I got a moment to feel that I was the tallest.
Yeah, hydration check.
Thank you.
Wait, are you saying that to Moe?
Well, excuse me.
What about mercy?
Moe seems to shake the encounter off and return to normal.
An ahiqo's words swirl in my head.
Our situation has done a complete reverse from where we were just a moment ago.
I can't believe I was complaining about not knowing what to investigate.
Oh, anyway, scream.
What was that?
A guard we met outside.
I'm going to let that pass.
For now, then bye.
I doubt there's anyone else here.
You might have seen something.
Wherever he is too.
Sounded like it came from far away.
A ways down the hallway.
Be the other side of the school.
Yeah, let's look for him.
If he screamed like that.
Something might have happened to him.
Right as I respond, hear someone whisper in my ear.
A pair of eyes.
Hold on.
A pair of eyes with red.
I look in the direction of the voice, but all I see is darkness.
Mystery?
No, it's nothing.
Let's go.
New info was added to the spirit file.
An ahiqo, the boy in the mirror.
Can I go up here?
Climbed the stairs.
Climbed up the stairs to the second floor.
I guess something soft squished under my heel.
Could I pick up my foot and shine the light down?
Oh, that's a lot of snacks.
Snacks.
Snacks, snacks.
So many snacks.
Hallways covered with poisonous snakes.
Come on, wait.
Let's have something close to a streak upon seeing them.
Eats and snakes!
Decided to go back to the landing.
Oh, let's go.
Went down the stairs.
I think we looked at these places.
A bird breaks the silence.
Like there's a crow or something outside.
Don't spook me now!
Oh, shut up.
It needs to be locked.
Lights on the ceilings are silent and dark without power.
Entered the left room.
I don't know what that fucking says.
There are nonsense scribbles on the blackboard.
There's a hole in the wall.
Yeah, stick my arm in, but the hole gets narrow and further I go in and can't reach
what's inside.
Tool.
Fire opener.
Pick the lever opener in the hole and scrape out the item though, second side.
A worn out talisman.
And I pick up the worn out talisman.
I feel warmth flow through me.
Oh, soul power.
A worn out talisman crumbles silently in my hand.
Find a worn out talisman to restore your soul power.
The more soul power you have, the easier it will be to survive a deadly choice.
Got an achievement for that.
An abandoned desk.
Yo, stick my hand inside and feel around.
A plastic bottle.
There's nothing in the bottle.
Oh, it might come in handy.
Senpai, are you scared?
I can't remember which way I'm going.
I hear a noise like something slamming against the door.
Is someone inside?
And the flashlight at the door.
No, not the security guard.
Yeah.
I don't know where the door bursts open and something comes flying out.
Moe shrieks and falls down.
I recognize those clothes.
Some kind of plant covers half his face.
The part of his face we can see is twisted in anguish as he screams.
No doubt about it, it's that guard.
How happened?
They're eating my face!
It hurts.
What's going on?
Uh-uh.
I'm sorry.
Moe sits on the floor, stunned into syllable.
The guards only rushes towards the entrance.
And then silence falls once more.
The only sound left is that of her shaky breathing.
Once we catch her breath, take Moe's hand and help them up.
Her nerves have calmed some, but that definitely left an unsettling impression.
Something terrible lurks here.
Can't just sit around.
I felt like I was paralyzed.
I'm okay now.
Mr. That Guy.
I'm always stares at the door.
I wonder if Anahiko did that.
And I don't know if you noticed, but I got the feeling someone was standing behind him.
There's really no good way to respond to that.
I let silence serve as my answer.
What else could I do?
No point in coming here for just going to stand here shaking.
Don't uncover the secret before it comes for us.
Let me check out the staff room.
Actually avoid answering Moe's question.
Guard had run out of here.
Something might be inside.
Some secret about Anahiko.
Yeah, yeah.
You're right.
Just be careful, okay?
I cover my wrist with my palm, making sure Moe doesn't miss.
The moment I put my hand on the knob,
a mark burned my skin, pulsing along with my beating heart.
New info is added to the spirit file.
Time to fight guard.
All right.
Record?
Let's check the memo out.
Anahiko?
A mysterious backrabbit appeared in front of us out of nowhere.
It's funny, but we've encountered so many strange things already.
And an odd bunny doesn't faze me at all.
Though this paralyzing dread might be concerning anyway.
Might be a bit concerning.
Anyway, first we have to find that mirror.
Anahiko with the boy in the mirror.
Like the rumor said, Gassley Boy appeared.
We answered some of his questions, then the mirror broke and he vanished.
No more big people here, he said.
Like who is chasing something, then we heard a horrible scream.
Came from the opposite end of the school.
It sounded familiar.
The mysteries didn't end there.
I heard a whisper in my ear and said,
Purify with red.
What was that eerie voice?
Maybe something was...
That's going on.
It's making me go crazy.
Regardless, we first need to find the true cause of that scream.
The guard we met at the school gate was the one who screamed.
Burst out of the staff room covered in growing plants of all things.
The pain was driving him mad.
The spirit do this?
It must have been Anahiko.
Which means...
Inside the staff room is what we have to keep going.
Okay, are you ready senpai?
I feel like I'm gonna piss.
The staff room is in chaos.
Furniture is upended and the walls are...
Is there a fire here or something?
There are black scorch marks everywhere.
Yeah.
Boy, it looks relieved as they come out from behind me.
Well, totally empty.
Anyway, let's look around.
There's a door here too.
It's like it goes to another room.
I search the burnt posts.
Something falls from the top of it.
It's bound to Warn out Talisman.
I pick up the Warn out Talisman and feel a warmth flow through me.
Got the soul power.
Warn out Talisman crumbles silently in my hand.
I think there's nothing else to do.
I think there's something else.
I think there's nothing else here, just here, walls near the window is burnt, there must
have been a fire here a long time ago.
Open the door and left the staff room.
I cramped in here.
Is this a storage room?
Seems?
It seems to be.
Hopefully there's something useful here.
There's a massive wooden cabinet.
It's really old, the corners of the doors are rounded off.
It's all in the door but just rattles in place.
Looks like it will open.
Something's stopping it.
Take out the letter opener.
What do I do with it?
I don't have any particularly good ideas.
Your little shit.
That one actually spooked me a little.
Oh, I just realized I'm super far away.
I opened the last door and checked inside.
There isn't anything that catches my eyes.
That actually kind of spooked me a little.
Good thing I did kegels.
Open the last door and check inside.
But there isn't anything that catches my eye.
I went into super comfy mode and just leaned back.
I think it's a school journal.
The paper deteriorated from ages and bugs so I can't read it.
There's a door cut in the floor.
Is it some kind of storage area?
A little bit.
Built door big enough to fit an adult through.
Feel?
My little head always retracted into the door.
I had to get a grasp on it and pull it out
but I am unsuccessful.
Letter opener again.
Easy, letter opener.
I might be able to pull the handle out.
Spot down by the door.
My mark bites into my wrists again.
It's almost like it's trying to stop me from searching under the floor.
Stand up pretending to be calm.
Hey, that's worrying.
I think dangerous must be here.
What's wrong?
Are you going to see what that is?
I'll check it out later.
Keep my reply big as I dust off my knees.
Let's look around the room first.
There's a bunch of interesting stuff in here.
I have nothing.
It's something beneath our feet.
We better make sure we're prepared for going down there.
Can I shake it more?
I feel it on the door but it just rattles in place.
Look.
I don't see it anywhere.
What's this?
Something stuck in the hole for the screw.
Seems that wooden thing works as a lock.
I have to do something about that to open the door.
Seriously?
I used the letter opener before?
I might be able to pop out whatever stuck in the hole.
That's the idea at least.
I hope it won't fit at all.
The knife is too big.
What else can I use?
Open the last door and check inside.
There isn't anything that catches my eye.
Anything else?
Oh, there's a box up there.
That's the cardboard box on top of the cabinet.
I think I can reach it.
Something's written on the marker at the side of the box.
Austin is legible but the rest of the letter smudged.
I feel.
Yep, I grabbed the box and looked inside.
Got lipstick, red pen, and girl slippers.
Good job, mister.
I knew there was a reason you were tall.
Shit.
Now that means...
Oops!
That's the wrong thing.
Examined first.
Tools.
Maybe I can use the red pen?
Take out the red pen.
I used the pen.
I might be able to pop open whatever's inside the hole.
Wow.
You've got skills.
Is that surprising?
Well, I need to focus.
Friendly.
Resistance vanishes and the pen pokes all the way through.
Hold my hand on the door and slide it open without any issue.
It's a red tube inside.
Got flair.
A flair?
What's that for?
I mean, you don't know what a flair is.
Also, the next book I may need to go potty.
It's a signal light for an emergency.
It's a good idea to always have one in your car.
Oh, okay then.
But, Moe, I picked something off the floor.
The thorn.
As long as my pinky finger.
That's what was in the hole.
I don't mean time call.
I'm a little nervous.
Not gonna lie.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm a little nervous.
This is so not a coincidence.
Bet he didn't want anyone to have that.
Put a thorn in the hole.
Is he scared of this?
You both look at the flair again.
Why did you turn off the light?
That wasn't me.
I didn't turn it off, it just went off.
What was that noise?
Hey mister, what was that noise?
Shh, be quiet.
Struggling not to yell with my nerves on edge.
I hit the flashlight again and again.
Come on, please.
The batteries were just working.
I feel like I'm performing CPR on this thing.
Finally.
Got it.
Door behind me warps threateningly.
I mark burns and pain.
Get this already in the room next door.
There's no time and nowhere to run.
Calm down.
We find a way out of this quickly.
We're running out of time.
We did survive, but got to hurry.
I cut the letter opener and shoved it in.
I might be able to get the handle out this way.
I touched the metal, my mark scored.
Not moving for just a second.
But I have to do this.
Yeah, I got it.
I grabbed the handle and lift up the trapdoor.
I thought a dark hole leads down under the floor.
Get in!
I shove Moe into the hole.
And I slide down into the darkness after them.
Ah!
I fall unexpectedly far, hitting my head.
Hitting my back against something.
Get my teeth to stop myself from yelling.
Something shuffling above my head.
If we had just stayed there just a few more seconds.
I grip my burning wrist with all my might.
I must endure the pain for now.
I can hear anxious panting.
Moe must be right next to me.
Making so hard, I can see it from the corner of my eye.
I brace myself, expecting the trapdoor to break open any second.
The shuffling noise.
It only grows distant.
Is it okay now?
Yeah.
I think it's gone.
Suddenly my wrist isn't hurting anymore.
Thank God, I thought we were done for this time.
Anyway, where are we?
Where in the world is this room?
I'm surprised this place exists beneath the school.
Can you turn on the light?
Yeah.
I cautiously press the switch, being careful not to make any noise.
Girls.
The scene captured in the light of the flashlight sends shivers down my spine.
Moe slaps a hand over her mouth.
In a few moments, all we can do is stare in silence.
It's sort of pretty with the flowers, I guess.
A disturbing scene, more horrible than anything I've ever seen before, spread out before us.
Anyone would be shocked by it, especially a kid.
I take a deep breath and look closer.
There's something twisting around the corpse.
It's like some kind of plant vine.
Those roses?
The strangely sharp thorns and the thin red petals.
They appear to be real.
Five roses covering the corpses and carpeting the floor.
My vision suddenly grows dim.
Ahh!
Don't look, Senpai! Don't look! Don't look!
Don't look!
I know! Don't look!
Don't look, Senpai!
Don't look!
I see a woman's body trapped by roses.
What? What is this?
The tragedy that happened in this room.
Don't look, Senpai!
As if it's all playing out in my head.
I can see it.
Girls? Girlses? What are they doing here?
Did someone plant them?
Okay.
You're safe, Senpai. Senpai.
I think you can look again.
Hmm. Hmm. Hmm.
Moe's voice brings me back to reality.
Hmm. Hmm. Hmm. Hmm.
Always protecting Senpai. Always protecting Senpai.
No ogling!
Yeah. I can't tell them what I...
I can't tell them that I saw some waking dream.
I scrambled to remember the conversation.
That's right. I saw the rose vines then.
It's got to be it.
It's not like they're just bringing up on their own.
Why would anyone do that?
Did someone decorate the corpse?
Is this for some kind of reason?
Did they die captured by the roses like I saw in the vision?
Moe screams.
What's wrong? What's wrong?
Something moved. See?
Over there! Back in there!
It's something hiding in here.
Mattress is completely discolored.
It's stained with something that looks like sweat.
Someone must have been living here for a long time, too.
Too old.
Letter opener?
It got the letter opener.
What do I do with it? I don't have any in particular!
Fuck! Do I just feel?
Mattress is oozing dark, dirty water.
Smells like sewage.
Slide the mattress over and find a plastic sheet underneath it.
Got a vinyl sheet!
Pretty thick.
Was it put there to protect from water damage?
Off of the sheet is pitch black.
At first glance, it looks like it's covered in mold.
I spread it open. It crunches as dark red flakes fall from it.
This is blood.
One endowed knife! I'm just going to point a knife at it!
Can't do anything, but whisper dumbfounded as I stare at the bloodstained sheet.
I think murmurs in my ear as I reply.
Their blood denies him.
Part of me takes the voice seriously.
I'm clearly hallucinating, but for some reason calms me down.
So in days, I shine the flashlight under the bed.
There it is again! Something's there!
Chloe's voice has gone very shrill.
What happened?
Hey, now. Give me a break.
I'm no monster, you know.
A regular human being.
Who are you?
Wait, I remember you. No, I remember you. I remember you.
I remember you. I remember you.
Nope, I remember you.
I play this far. Yeah. Wait, I remember you.
It's fine. It's fine. Who are you?
This is why I grabbed the knife.
Something slowly climbs out from under the bed.
It's a man in a trench coat.
A person? What were you doing under there?
The man looks bored. He scoffs.
The same as you.
And that monster escaped down here.
And you guys came.
The man turns his back to us and jerks his chin.
Anyhow, I was hiding over there.
His answer is believable enough.
But why is he at the school to begin with?
His presence raises a lot of questions.
The man tilts his head a bit and peers at me and snorts.
He seems through me.
You don't look like you believe...
You don't look like you believe me.
I guess that's only natural.
I haven't told you everything either.
I could, but...
The man looks around at his feet.
Better get out of here first.
I shouldn't chat at a crime scene.
I think you're right.
Oh, he seems to feel the same way.
Let's head back for now.
You have somewhere to go back to? Good.
Then let's get going.
The man puts his hand on the ladder.
He pauses and turns to us.
The name's Satoru Mashita.
I'm an ex-detective.
I forgot to mention that.
The man named Mashita disappears up the ladder.
We follow him back up to the first floor.
But when we emerge, he's not there.
Hey, take a look at this.
Mashita's calling us from down the hallway.
Was it like this when you guys came through?
Oh, he pipes up, voice slightly wobbly.
No, it wasn't.
It wasn't like this at all.
Something's creeping along the hallway.
The rose finds.
Not so.
I didn't see them before either.
Oh, ow!
The mark's color grow more vivid.
Early dawn, a few hours left until death closes in.
Some people naturally put others on guard,
even if there's no particular ill will between them.
It's exactly the type of person Mashita is.
Oh, you've got nice stuff here.
The moment he climbs in the car, he makes a grab for my bag,
and he starts inspecting all of my stuff.
I wasn't planning on keeping a constant eye on him,
but he's making it very hard not to.
Oh, he seems like the type to stick her nose in everything,
but he's suspiciously silent as if exhausted.
Are you okay, Moe?
Huh? Oh, yeah, just zoning out, you know?
I'm fine.
He doesn't look fine, but my other passenger is of more concern right now.
So, were you at the school because you were investigating something?
I'm not on the force anymore, just poking around for my own reasons.
Something I wanted to check.
I don't doubt what he says, but that would mean he entered the school illegally.
What were you?
Let me ask one thing first.
Mashita interrupts my question and points to my arm.
Does that hurt?
It doesn't take him long to spot the mark on my wrist.
Sometimes it hurts the most whenever I'm in danger.
Huh, is that so?
Mashita leans back in his seat, satisfied.
I was investigating some missing people.
Guess he's responding to my question now.
That school came up with a number of missing persons cases.
Each one had some affiliation with age elementary before they disappeared.
Teachers, workers, people in the BTA, students and their family members.
I was looking for them.
Then...
Moe speaks up from the back seat.
Are those people?
The corpses down there?
Doesn't sound as energetic as she usually did.
Does something happen after all?
Is her mark?
Mashita doesn't reply.
Maybe he thinks the answer is obvious, or maybe replying to a kid isn't worth his time.
Something bugs me about what he just said.
The school was clearly suspicious then.
Of course, I brought it up to my superiors.
All I got for it was...
Continues before I can ask, making a slashing motion across his neck.
You got fired, huh?
Disciplinary discharge, something about sexually harassing us, so burden it!
That principal's gotta get some kind of pull, gotta have some kind of political pull.
I probably dug up something he didn't want to get out.
That wasn't my plan, I never meant to uncover anything dirty.
True, the school did have that suspicious room.
Not that strange to think it would come up in some missing persons cases.
That would be common sense at least.
Common sense is for the world of the living.
The spirit might have something to do with those cases.
There's an awkward silence.
In that sense, this isn't even a case anymore, is it?
I should just size deeply.
I would believe it.
I would believe that there's a monster in that school killing people.
It's personal now.
Our problem.
And we're on our own.
He turns his wrist over and shows it to me.
On his skin is the familiar mark.
Yeah, I sensed it as soon as I saw yours.
I had a feeling this would be a problem.
We're in the same boat, you and I.
He's got good instincts.
We should talk more when we get back.
At Kujo Mansion, there's some...
Stopped myself from finishing my sentence.
I shouldn't mention that for now.
In any case, once we get back, we'll give you more details.
Yeah, I'm sure they'll help him a bunch.
Yeah, I'll share that to help him a bunch.
Who the fuck said that?
I might as she takes off.
Is that Moe?
So hard when all of them are in the same color.
Yeah, she did help him a lot.
Help, huh?
You're underestimating me.
Who the do's a pale or an orange?
You think I can tell the difference?
When I got out from the car,
someone's there to keep me.
Welcome back, mister.
You too, Miss Moe.
Well, you're unharmed.
Any clues about the spirit?
What?
So there's others.
This is everyone.
Huh, what a reliable group you've got.
The sarcasm is practically dripping off his words.
So...
Are you all planning to continue to search for that key or whatever it is?
I don't have anything to go on.
There's no other choice.
I don't understand you.
The source of the mark is the spirit.
It would be best to destroy the source, don't you think?
What do you mean?
The spirit exists, so all you have to do is kill it.
Are you serious?
Of course he's serious.
He doesn't exactly look like the joking type.
Even if we manage to kill it, will that really make the mark disappear?
When I considered everything Mary's told me, it doesn't look like it would work that way.
Even assuming it did would have a more fundamental problem.
How do you plan to kill it?
I'll figure something out.
If something exists, there's logically a way to destroy it as well.
He claims he can kill the spirit yet he doesn't even know how to do it.
This is all that confidence come from.
Don't forget, I faced him once already.
If we're seriously thinking of killing him.
Actually there are graphs as well.
A little shit took a shot.
Wow, these are hard to read. Hold on.
The little shit shot some kind of thorn at me from a distance.
Hit me hard enough to stick in concrete. No way to get close to him.
I have to make that a priority.
Mash it up, pull something out of the hue of his shoe and toss it to me.
The thorn curved like a thing.
The only reason I'm still breathing is because I was lucky.
It won't happen next time. We need a plan.
If we head to the entrance, I tell Mashita about Kujo Mansion.
He takes it all in silently.
Even bringing up the talking doll or Saiya Kujo's death doesn't trigger a reaction.
Why is he so unnervingly calm?
Because he's already dealt with the supernatural?
We reach the main hall which is warmly lit.
This is a strange mansion, but for some reason I feel like I've come home.
A climatization is kind of terrifying.
Welcome back, my darling.
That man is a markbearer too, I see.
Would you make the introductions?
I update Mary on our investigation in the strange way we met Mashita.
The mirror, the underground room full of corpses, the sudden appearance of roses.
I really hate to admit it, but it's clear something supernatural is at work.
And the spirit that is the cause of all of it?
Hanahiko.
There's no doubt that Hanahiko is the one who put the mark on Mashita's arm too.
But...
Stop flashbanging me!
What kind of chance do we have against a monster that can do that?
Weed killer, okay, you know what?
But are roses weeds?
I don't think so.
Mashita says we should kill him.
Is that even possible?
Hey, darling.
Sorry.
I didn't know who that was, so I was like...
Darling.
Okay, so now it's, hey, darling.
Oops, I dropped my bopple.
My little ice rollers.
My train of thought is interrupted.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Senpai.
My fujiyo mind is racing.
I'm starting to make fan fiction in my head.
But then I remembered our protagonist is Senpai, so now I'm just like,
maybe I should scrap that idea.
My train of thought is interrupted.
Mashita's holding a leather-bound notebook out towards me.
Read this.
I picked it up in that underground room.
It was caught up in a bunch of those rose vines when I found it.
It was pretty hard to get loose.
Did you read it?
I skimmed through a bit.
It's got some interesting stuff.
I saw.
That's what he says.
But he's not smiling at all.
It's a shimmer.
A shimmer with a quiet anger.
I was like, shimmer.
No, that's not a shimmer.
Dark red mark staying the cover.
I have a bad feeling that I flipped through it.
Rose petals fall as they become unstuck from the pages.
The notes within are very detailed.
The author was intelligent and well-written.
Reading through it dawns on me that this was written by H. Elementary's principal.
The austere, meticulous letter on each page tell a ghastly story.
The skirts of a young, adopted boy's tutoring sessions.
The first note is from five years ago.
It seems the boy adopted by the principal was small and exceedingly cute.
He enjoyed wearing skirts and makeup too.
I was so denying that they truly suited a dainty red-cheeked boy like him.
But the principal had a hard time accepting such fancies.
Bad habits must be corrected.
Young must be corrected young to promote sound, mental and healthy thought.
So he called it tutoring as a cover for his warped desires.
They took place in the underground room.
Too many prying eyes anywhere else.
There was no safer place than the school at night.
Once all the teachers had left.
No! No!
The principal stayed behind under the pretense of keeping watch, then tutored.
He was a highly respected teacher.
He even made appearances on TV.
There's no reason to be suspicious.
The only one who noticed anything strange was the boy's homeroom teacher.
But she feared the principal's power and firmly kept her mouth shut.
As the notes continue, they are more and more deranged.
They paint a horrible picture.
It is of a totally distorted parent and child.
My child gets weaker after every session.
His delicate frame has grown thinner and his red cheeks are now darkened.
His appearance is described in detail.
There is no malice or hatred.
It's just fanatical sincerity is pride as an educator.
And a terrifying smothering love.
I don't like where this is going!
It continues like that to the very last page.
There's no mention of what became of the principal and the boy.
Going by the current state of H elementary, I can hazard a guess.
You don't look so well, mister.
I was in the notebook.
The cast up here is up at me.
He and the boy in the notebook are about the same age.
This is the stuff you share with the kid.
I better just sum up the main points for him.
That's terrible.
Each children are always the victims of eagles of adults.
Stupid grown ups are irredeemable!
Okay, chill!
Chill, kid!
Why do you say that makes sense?
Yeah, but kid, chill!
I know!
The revolting evil of adults and the poor boy who became a victim.
But is that really the end?
If Hanahiko and the boy in the notebook are connected,
and the boy turned into a monster, is that even possible?
I'm like, yeah, I get it!
I get it, kid!
I get it, just chill, chill!
Untimely deaths produce hatred.
Death does not bring it to an end.
Such festering sentiments can give birth to the supernatural.
Monsters, ghosts, vengeful spirits, they have many names.
I believe that you have all heard one or two such stories.
And an eagle is similar.
Mary's words are hard to swallow.
After all those weird events, it only makes sense to accept them.
If I turn my back to the truth, all that will await me is death.
And who's talking?
And Hanahiko is really a monster.
Yeah, you must form a plan based off of that hypothesis.
Who's talking?
Mary is silent a moment.
Then her jade glass eyes shift to Mashita.
Incidentally, according to Lord Darling's report,
there are those amongst you who are considered killing the spirit.
Wait, what the fuck is talking?
There are those among you who are considering killing the spirit.
I shall warn you just in case.
That would be very difficult to do.
Why is that?
I could see Mashita in Nero's eyes, but I made sure to speak up first.
They are from the world of the dead.
Just as the living cannot become more alive,
the dead cannot be killed.
The only thing that could possibly destroy is the cursed sentiment.
So what does that mean?
It's as I told you before, death and life existing together.
If that is the origin of the mark, no way to erase it will be there.
I swear they need to add name plates to someone because I don't know who's talking sometimes.
By driving away the spirit, the curse will also be eliminated.
So defeating Hena Hiko is how we'll be able to destroy the mark.
Setting aside how he can't be killed, what exactly is the key then?
There's nothing more than a concept.
I am unsure, but I am certain of one thing.
Fate ties the spirit to its place of birth.
An object there may be able to fill the role of the key.
It's a difficult concept to grasp, but that is just how spirits are.
Determining the nature of the key, that would aside your fate.
I had a feeling we'll have to keep digging around each elementary.
We don't know what cursed sentiments or the key is destroying the grudge.
We don't know what the cursed sentiments or the key to destroying the grudges are.
Gaining the key and lifting the grudge is the only way to survive.
It would be required to be callous to make use of the spirit's fear.
The way to repel the spirit lies within its grudge.
Remember this, and be careful, and be careful.
New info was added to the spirit file, the secret of the underground room.
I think Senpai, is this a good place to save?
Because I know we didn't get too far in this visual novel, but I'm a little tired.
I'm a little tired.
It's been a long day, Senpai.
Mm-mm.
Oops.
I don't remember.
I can go yet and it's here.
Ugh.
I'm so sleepy.
Yeah, I wanna leave a-
I wanna leave the game.
Wah!
I hope to get the best sleep.
Senpai, I will.
Also, Senpai was very good and didn't look.
You kept yourself pure.
I'd like to review next week's...
Next week's...
So tomorrow, when I said I was slowing down, that was a total lie for this week,
so I checked the following week is when I go to three streams.
Instead, next week is also five streams.
It's five streams.
It's not an entire week, so I'm not fully exhausted.
But tomorrow, we're back here again.
What terrible life advice!
Give me your life, give me your questions through morals.
Or ask them in chat.
Mostly, I would mostly appreciate it if you asked them through morals.
By morals, I mean marshmallows.
Scroll down.
Go down.
And ask questions about or send me your questions.
And I will give you the answers that you need.
Is it going to be good answers?
Probably not.
Is it answers?
Yeah, actually, it's gonna be answers.
What do marshmallows do you get a day?
It really depends.
Sometimes, I have...
I get lots of morals, and sometimes, I get not too many morals.
And then, some days, I'm like...
And then, some days, it's just not very nice morals.
And I'm just like, oh, whatever.
Between one to a lot, a few?
A few, I guess?
A few, I guess, so...
Right now, I probably have about 200 morals I have to go through.
Some of them I don't really answer, because I'm just like taking them to heart, and I'm just like, thank you.
Although, I should probably give them hearts, because I haven't been doing that.
I have around 200 morals, plus...
Yeah, so...
Yeah, we've been getting a lot of morals.
A lot of them, I feel bad if I repeat them.
But I should probably start hearting some morals to let some pies know that I've read them.
So I think, yeah, that's pretty, yeah.
That's a lot of morals.
I don't answer it as much as my senpai, not my senpai story, my genmais.
Wow, I'm mixing you up, senpai on the mind, senpai brain rot.
That...
I'm not as active, because I'm kind of awkward, and I don't know what to reply.
And if I feel like I just say, oh, thank you, senpai, or wow, that was really hot senpai, I feel like...
I feel like it's not a good enough response.
So then I don't answer, and then I feel worse.
Don't put your genmates in the basement.
I'm a steak.
I think they're fine, I can recognize them.
I'll be like, I'll lift up, I'll be like, oh, you don't go there.
He shone the forehead.
Yeah, likewise I never know what to write for similar reasons.
I don't know what to say.
Otherwise, other than, thank you for supporting me.
I'm kind of stupid.
But yeah, tomorrow will be terrible life advice plush marshmallow Q&A.
I can fully say that I'm not really prepared for it, so I can just...
It's probably going to be just saying, saying stuff.
And maybe mixed in with the terrible life advice is some actual life advice.
Who knows?
Going in.
And then I get a day off.
But luckily on that day off, I think my second audio for Patreon is released.
So you can have that in my stead.
Then I'm continuing Omari.
And then I'm doing Power Wash Simulator, which is my first collab.
No wait, technically my second collab with my genmates.
And then after that is Zatsu Yapping.
So I just yapp about whatever.
Probably updates saying...
Probably updates about how I'm feeling, what's it like to be in VLR so far, etc.
Then after that, Saturday I have a break.
Then Sunday I have an unarchived karaoke stream.
So it'll be unarchived.
I'll be singing, you know, songs.
Maybe not well, but I'll be singing.
So yeah, I hope some friends can tune into that.
Or if you're like, wow, that schedule seems like it sucks.
Don't tune in, just kill.
And then I'll see you next week, I guess.
But yeah, I really want to play Harvester again.
So I'm going to play Harvester and Killer 7 again.
So I'd really love to see that.
Anyway, you sing is the correct way.
We are a captive audience.
Mercy singing us to us is always welcome.
Don't get the holes.
Be nice to me, senpai.
It's going to be my first time singing in front of my senpai.
So I think I'll be a little bit more nervous than usual.
I'll probably be singing songs I'm familiar with and some new songs that I'm just like, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, yeah.
That's it for today.
Let me check.
What's going on?
Oh my gosh, Azura is still live?
Give me a second, senpai.
I forget how to do this, but I'm going to figure out how to raid.
I forgot how to do it.
It's always because my gen mates raid into me.
Raid into me and I'm not really the one.
Okay, hold on.
I think I found it.
Please wait for me.
Okay, senpai.
What is this?
This?
I found it.
I found a senpai.
She's live.
I can redirect.
I can do it.
Okay, senpai.
It should redirect now and if it doesn't, just go over there, okay?
I love you, senpai.
See you again tomorrow.
And I'm going to rest up now.
Thank you.
I'm so sorry that I was so very tired and messing and stumbling on my words.
I was just...
I was not there.
Thank you, senpai.
And I'll see you again next time.
Scream for Mercy!
Bye-bye!
Mwah!